the bank of england governor thinks we
are facing a historic squeeze as a
result of this energy crisis
the shock from energy prices this year
will be larger than any single year in
the 1970s
larger than any single year in the 1970s
but actually he might be understating it
a little bit and to see why you need to
look at what's going on with those
energy prices starting with wholesale
gas prices this is basically what your
energy company is spending its money on
and we thought that that peak that you
can see there last winter was high well
then came the the russian invasion of
ukraine and just look at what happened
to gas prices after that historic peaks
there but they have come down quite
interestingly look that line has gone
down a little bit in the last few weeks
why is that it's partly because there is
still gas flowing from russia through to
the eu surprising this isn't it but just
look actually the flows have gone up to
the highest level so far this year that
line is up to the highest level so far
this year this year despite the invasion
so there's a lot going on that we need
to kind of unpick here that feeds
through to our bills but let's have a
look at our bills and just how much of
our spending goes on those bills we're
looking back here all the way to 1957
and you can see this blue area here
that's the kind of range of what we've
tended to spend our money on when it
comes to these energy bills you can see
it's been within that range it's come
down a bit uh in recent years but as we
all know it's going up and as of the end
of this week it is going up uh to just
under two thousand pounds that's the
energy price cap differs depending on on
the size of your home
but that's the highest level since the
mid 1980s on average um the question
though is what happens next does it go
up as the obr said last week to 2800
pounds in october because of those extra
increases in gas prices that's what they
said last week but here's the thing on
top of that you've got to bear in mind
that the chancellor has stepped in with
some money 350 pounds in total council
tax and rebates so if you factor that in
for the average home if you do get those
those rebates and so on you're still
talking about that red line being the
highest that we've ever seen so higher
than anything since the 1950s but you've
got to also bear in mind those gas
prices are yo-yoing around a lot and
every day they change so does the
calculation for what we're going to be
paying uh in october so right now the
latest numbers suggest we're talking
about not maybe 2800 more like 2500 2490
the price cap so once you then take off
the 350 pounds that by the way is
obviously the highest that we've ever
seen but take off the 350 and you're in
that territory uh which is similar a
little bit worse than we're going to see
in april still the worst since the early
1980s but not historically
bad that is why the chancellor and
everyone else is going to be keeping an
eye on what happens to those gas prices
over the next few weeks